yourself
[Music]
foreign
they said they killed jesus but they
killed him not right the jew says
that they killed him but they killed him
but in another part of the quran it says
blessed is he in the day he's born
blessed to see in the day
i mortify him kill him and bless to see
the day i raise him up so
when christian put them verses to you
it's like you guys saw and carry on your
agenda
my question is could you not say you
ain't died and then your own quran is
saying
blessed is the day is born blessed is
the day i kill him
multiply the word arab mortified
and the day i raised him up so i'm just
trying to say
now this is where your argument is the
argument of my friends is
the quran says jesus did not die on the
cross but hold on a second
here it says and peace be upon me the
day i was born the day i should die and
the day i should be raised life again
so what my friend is saying what's your
name jersey jose nice to meet you my
name is
so what he's saying is that look it
doesn't make sense to me first you claim
you did not die
now another verse in the quran says he
died yeah valid point but a
misunderstanding
so what he's saying is peace be upon me
the day i was born
jesus was born yeah that day i shall
die can you read the arabic
the word is mortified multiplied in the
i mean in greek mortified
and it's mortified means kill no
no no no trace the word trace the word
it's
multiplied from the word
my understanding is multiply multiplies
it says peace be upon me that there was
born nobody jesus was born
yeah the day i shall die
now you're taking that as jesus died
we're saying no
we believe jesus is not dead till this
day he's with god almighty
he's going to come back in his second
coming and he's going to claim to the
people of the book so you're taking that
to the end no no no
no no because he is very clear because
otherwise he'll contradict yourself
peace be upon me the day i was born
the day i shall die meaning that jesus
is going to come back
he's going to live he's going to die and
the day i shall be raised up again yeah
that's the gospel
it came
great if he was this miracle in the
cradle yeah and he spoke again it
doesn't mean he spoke when he was in
adult age because that's not a miracle
i'm an adult i'm speaking that's not a
miracle
so what's the miracle the miracle that
is spoken
i understand i understand your point and
where you're coming from but the point
is you see
a miracle if he speaks when he stood up
in israel i completely understand and
agree with you
but the thing is that was taken from the
gospel of thomas
which came two hundred years later and
it's been proven a fool jerry okay but
okay okay so what i'm saying is this
here that we believe
jesus did not die neither he was
crucified god
saved him from the ones that wanted to
kill him jesus is going to come back
and tell the people of the book yeah the
christians our christian uh
brothers and sisters in humanity that he
never said he's good
you're gonna kill pigs and they're gonna
kill crosses and break crosstalk no no
the reason why he's gonna break the
cross
is to because in the end he's gonna get
married and die
okay yeah
wants to have kids and living for four
years and then to come on
you man you're right come on that's what
we're talking about
you're saying you're saying that jesus
he's gonna come back right but he never
died on a cross but when he comes back
he's gonna break crosses kill pigs and
then he's gonna find a wife marry her
have some kids and then die
yeah good okay what's the problem that's
coming here don't run away yeah
it's almost
if i meant that you should laugh you
know why
you said that are you telling me
this reason is gonna come back live get
married and die god is gonna get married
and die
that's our point to our christian
sisters and friends brothers in humanity
what we're trying to say is let's come
to common term that we worship god alone
we do not believe jesus was god why
because jesus was a
we believe in his miracles we believe in
his miraculous birth we love him
no muslim can be a muslim why is he so
difficult let me tell you something
we believe jesus was a mighty messenger
yeah i could if i said to you guys god
came to earth
ate food when we eat food we have to go
toilet yeah
now we believe in god we say god is
worthy of my worship if i ask you guys
to bow down to my ipad would you do it
by that say thank you ipad for my food
today
yeah now the reason we worship god five
times a day
is because he's worthy of it yeah so let
me give you an example
i'll give you an ipad
[Music]
you have thanked me for something i've
done for you yeah we believe that we
thank god
regardless he's worthy of worship yeah
everything that i have here everything
that he's done even looking at the
creation it's like it's magnificent
perfect so what we do is we praise him
we do not believe he was a man why
because we believe man is weak but it is
not weak man is
not knowing god is unknowing so that's
why when jesus was asked
uh by the israelites when when is the
hour he said i do not know
neither do the angels accept mine now
he's referred to us father but we do not
believe in that term
we call him god even when some of his
the sabbath came to him said oh good
master
what must i do to get eternal life he
said why do you call me good
there is only one good and that's god
alone so what we're trying to do is this
person you know that verse there
you know that birthday we said to him
why'd you call me good
are you calling me god because the man
he had not
he had not manifested himself as god so
the man's coming good rather a good
rabbi
yeah so jesus is pointing why are you
calling me god why are you calling me
good
no but one thing right the question you
don't know if i'm good you know why are
you calling me
can you say to me the fact that you're
saying god is going to come down get
married and die
yes
you know what you said about the food
about we eat and we got a toilet god
does not do that right
in genesis 22 god yahweh
presented himself in front of abraham
with three men they sat down and had a
meal
with god
yet a meal with abraham right hear
yourself
god this is what the scripture is saying
this is our opinion
the scriptures are right or the
scriptures are wrong look at what you're
saying scriptures are right
god ate a with abraham
with abraham that's okay god
ain't new with abraham yes
okay i find that troubling yeah you
would find trouble because your friend
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
the problem is you are thinking fleshly
right
god is different dimensional jesus
appeared to his apostles
in a clocked room right then he said put
the breakfast on cook a fish
they cooked the fish here and then he
disappeared
his dimension he can that food he
doesn't have to go to the toilet
he's don't mention do you understand
you're not so you know you're not
grasping
listen attributes of god you're supposed
to go with your theory
if you're going to agree with that then
that means god can come in a man he can
come into anything
according to that theory so let me ask
you a question why in a man
a man well god god came in a tree in the
quran he spoke from a tree in the quran
and you need to know the truth of jesus
christ that's why man
can you just kind of because the thing
is we're going to different topics
did you not say to me and laugh at me
the fact that god came down and got
married
now you're saying god can get god can't
get married he can't come here and die
but god can have
he's not saying he can't say it's stupid
because that's he he can't marry
how's he gonna marry his creation he
created a creation like
this young lady here how can you high
school gonna come up you're making my
point come and stand here with me all
right
we need to get here i'm gonna talk to
you come here go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go you guys stand there we made
you happy then you talk to yourself
you're making the point for me
and become a man or come as a man can i
say this thing
god is very powerful right can god
become a chair can god become a chair
the reason is why would he can he become
a chair why would he
okay but okay but why would he
that shows that shows that it doesn't
show its power
god is logical what you're suggesting is
illogical
we can't say god show me how powerful
you are become my dreams let me wear it
yeah no because
oh god if you can become whatever even
in your creation or you become
a sausage roll it doesn't show his power
it shows his power
we say god does what benefits his
majesty so i can't come and say god why
don't you become a tree
because god has made the truth god is
the most powerful yes yes
he don't know him oh no okay i'm
yourself you're not
assuming god's power creational power
and god's transcendent power to earn to
become a man
you're just talking about any normal man
right we're talking about
christ the holy spirit overshadowed mary
and the holy thing was conceived
that christ existed before
christ created mary just to put it into
your head he created his mother
do you understand what i'm saying jesus
existed before his
birth before his incarnation
it does make sense
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
i